[Music]  you  are an infinite  evan mccauley  diagnosed with schizophrenia at 14  after carving the words look inside into  your chest  with a box cutter look inside  why those words  which one of these is yours  look you could skip the whatever the  hell this is because none of that is  mine  [Music]  was it yours i don't know what you're  talking about anyway  jesus every time you say i don't know  this trigger guess paul is it yours  look i don't know are you out of your  mind  last chance evan is  this yours  hello old friend  oh get in  this isn't your first life evan  you are an infinite  you've lived  [Applause]  and died  a thousand times  you're talking about reincarnation  if you can remember who you were  you will understand who you can become  [Music]  you